We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Chicago is next. If you want to stand out as a skyscraper in Chicago, you've got your work cut out for you.
我们得到了加利福尼亚大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界上面临的最紧迫的食品、能源、健康、教育和环境问题。UC戴维斯的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。接下来是芝加哥。如果你想在芝加哥成为一座脱颖而出的摩天大楼，那可真得下一番功夫了。
I've stood at this corner a zillion billion times and never looked up at this building. There's the Hancock building. there's the Sears Tower. Yeah, you're supposed to call it the Willis Tower now. Yeah, I'm not gonna call it this. No! And then there's my friend Dan Weissman's new favorite building in the South Loop. A couple days ago, I was at the Cultural Center,
我在这个街角站过无数次，却从未抬头看过这座建筑。那边有汉考克大厦，那边是西尔斯大厦。对，现在你应该叫它威利斯大厦。好吧，我才不这么叫呢。才不！然后还有我的朋友丹·韦斯曼在南环路的新最爱建筑。几天前，我在文化中心，
and there's like a map of Chicago architectural landmarks. I mean, it's got zillions of buildings on it. Houses, everything, and this building's not on it. Even if a building is designed by a prominent architect. It's by this guy, Harry Weiss, who made the DC Metro. He's a big deal. And even if that building has only three sides, it's like a triangle from above.
那里有一张芝加哥建筑地标的地图。我的意思是，上面有无数的建筑。房子、各种设施，但这栋建筑不在上面。即使这座建筑是由一位杰出的建筑师设计的。它是哈里·维斯设计的，他设计了华盛顿地铁。他是个大人物。而且即使这座建筑只有三个面，从上方看就像一个三角形。
Like a grilled cheese sandwich, cut in half, diagonally. And has these a regularly placed long vertical windowslets. It's just like a punch card or a scantron card. It's still hard to stand out as a skyscraper in Chicago. I remember the first time I noticed it. I was like, what is that building? Someone there was like, oh, it's a jail. My name is Jack Hartray. I was the project manager on the Campbell Correctional Center. Which most people know as the Metropolitan Correctional Center or MCC. It's a federal detention facility. It's where you stay when you're waiting to go up on trial in the federal courthouse, which is like two blocks away. When it was built, nobody much like the idea
就像一个烤奶酪三明治，沿对角线切成两半。并且有这些不规则排列的细长垂直窗缝。它就像一张打孔卡或机读卡。在芝加哥，想要作为摩天大楼脱颖而出依然很难。我记得我第一次注意到它的时候。我在想，那是什么建筑？旁边有人说，哦，那是座监狱。我叫杰克·哈特雷。我是坎贝尔惩教中心的项目经理。大多数人称之为大都会惩教中心或MCC。这是一个联邦拘留设施。这是你在等待联邦法院审判期间待的地方，联邦法院就在两个街区外。当它建造时，没多少人喜欢这个主意
of a federal jail downtown. The mayor didn't want this building built in the loop. It's right across the street from a club called the Union League Club, which is one of the kind of fancy elite clubs in the city, and people were like, we don't want prisoners, you know, moaning us from the windows of the jail, and it doesn't seem like it's going to be really good for property values. So there was a lawsuit actually. But to their legal misfortune, they had to bring the student federal court to the only people who were going to
在市中心建一座联邦监狱。市长不想在环路建造这座建筑。它就在一个叫联盟俱乐部（Union League Club）的俱乐部对面，这是城里那种豪华的精英俱乐部之一，人们当时觉得，我们可不想让囚犯们从监狱的窗户向我们抱怨，而且这似乎对房地产价值也没什么好处。所以实际上发生了一场诉讼。但出于他们法律上的不幸，他们必须把学生联邦法院带到唯一会审理的人那里去
hear the suit. We're also the only people in town who wanted the thing built. They were federal judges. And I think it took them about, you know, 12 minutes to get the thing kicked out of the court. It was impossible to get a judge that wasn't in favor of building the building. The architects in Harry Wies' group were tickled by the prospect as well. Jack Hartray, who worked on the building, said, I think everybody in the office figured that you had a certain number of unindicted criminals in the city and then you had something that had gotten caught. The MCC was just for the people who happened to have gotten caught.
审理这起诉讼的人，也是城里唯一想建这座建筑的人。他们是联邦法官。我想他们大概花了12分钟就把这个案子从法院踢出去了。根本不可能找到一个不支持建造这座建筑的法官。哈里·维斯团队的建筑师们对这个前景也感到非常高兴。参与这座建筑设计的杰克·哈特雷说，我想办公室里的每个人都认为，这座城市里本来就有一定数量未被起诉的罪犯，然后还有一些被抓获的人。MCC只是为那些恰好被抓到的人准备的。
And because the architects took it seriously, that the inmates were innocent until proven guilty. They thought, let's make this as nice as we can. You know, somebody already looked at this problem. How do you make a really small space? Cozy. Harry sort of viewed this from the standpoint of the accommodations on sailboats. The furniture was all built in,
正因为建筑师们认真对待了“ inmates（犯人）在被证明有罪之前是无辜的”这一理念。他们想，让我们尽力把这里建得好一点。你知道，已经有人研究过这个问题了。如何让一个非常小的空间变得温馨。哈里某种程度上是从帆船舱室的角度来看待这个问题的。家具都是内置的，
so you could really do pretty nice furniture. Built-in, hardwood furniture has these really clean lines, the bed, there's a desk. I've seen this picture, it's really, you know, it's nice. We built rooms to scale in our office and my children used to come down and take naps and they love the interior space. It was kind of an element pleasant. It was cozy. Yeah.
所以你真的可以做出非常漂亮的家具。内置的硬木家具线条非常干净，有床，还有书桌。我看过这张照片，它真的很漂亮。我们在办公室里按比例建造了房间，我的孩子们以前经常下来睡午觉，他们非常喜欢内部空间。这有点像一个令人愉快的元素。很温馨。是的。
And those narrow slit windows I mentioned earlier, those are Florida ceiling windows to let in as much light as possible. But they're also built just narrow enough at five inches so that they were within the federal guidelines of the time to not need bars. Sounds really nice. No, it is nice. Yeah nice. Oh it is nice.
而我之前提到的那些狭窄的缝隙窗户，那是落地窗，为了尽可能引入光线。但它们的宽度也恰好控制在五英寸，刚好符合当时联邦规定的不需要加装栏杆的标准。听起来真不错。不，确实很好。对，很好。哦，真的很好。
Yeah, it is nice. It's not a bad place to stay. I saw an interview with Harry Weasley where he said what he had in mind was like a hotel. Well, we were doing a hotel at the same time and this was better than the hotel, you know, as far as the building furniture and all of that. I showed me the hotel, you know, as far as the the building furniture and all of that. Uh, show me the hotel. Dan has a reporter's tenacity like you wouldn't believe, but he just couldn't get the warden to let him in to the MCC to see if all these beautiful Harry Weas interiors and designs
对，真的很不错。这不是一个糟糕的住处。我看到过对哈里·维斯的采访，他说他脑海中的设计就像一家酒店。嗯，我们当时正在设计一家酒店，而这个甚至比酒店还要好，就建筑家具以及所有这些而言。向我展示了这家酒店，就建筑家具以及所有这些而言。呃，展示这家酒店。丹有着你难以置信的记者坚韧精神，但他就是无法让典狱长让他进入MCC，去看看所有这些漂亮的哈里·维斯室内设计
were still intact. So I called around thinking like who gets inside these places and I ended up talking to a guy named Phil Carigan. If you were to the facility and talk to a random bunch of detainees, they would be a gas that the description or maybe want to go over and clutch a throat. That is not the case. Phil Carigan has been going to the MCC for over 10 years. He has kind of a designated volunteer for the MCC and he goes and visits guys who don't have anybody else to visit them. MCC is not a star.
是否仍然完好无损。所以我到处打电话，心想谁能进到这些地方里面去，最后我和一个叫菲尔·卡里根的人聊了聊。如果你去那个设施并和随机的一群被拘留者交谈，他们会对这种描述大吃一惊，或者可能想过去掐住你的喉咙。事实并非如此。菲尔·卡里根去MCC已经超过10年了。他是MCC的一种指定志愿者，他去探访那些没有其他人去探访的人。MCC可不是什么明星建筑。
It's very drab, gunmetal gray. You know, the physical facility is nothing to show off. The cells, the architect described this being really nice, all this kind of hardwood built-in furniture for instance. They're gone. The bumps are steel, two-tier structures, no wood. And do you have sunlight coming in? No.
它非常单调，呈炮铜灰。你知道，实体设施没什么好炫耀的。那些牢房，建筑师曾将其描述为非常漂亮，例如所有这些硬木内置家具。它们已经不在了。双层床是钢制的两层结构，没有木头。那有阳光照进来吗？没有。
The windows are generally frosted. It doesn't allow for sunlight to come in. And the place is old, definitely undergone some changes, and none of them have been for beautification. By the time Dan talked with Robert Brogman, who wrote a book about Harry Weas, he was pretty bummed out. There's something about this that seems kind of sad to me. You know, Harry Weiss is a brilliant architect,
窗户通常是磨砂的。不允许阳光照进来。而且这个地方很旧，确实经历了一些变化，而且没有一个是为美化而做的。当丹与写过关于哈里·维斯的书的罗伯特·布罗格曼交谈时，他感到非常沮丧。这件事有些地方让我觉得挺悲哀的。你知道，哈里·维斯是一位杰出的建筑师，
and this seems like it's one of his signature projects. His conception is not what exists today. True, but you know, there are Harry Weiss buildings going down all over the country, and that's true of almost all architect of that period. So it was a minor matter that the inside of a place that was never meant to be public has been changed. You know, it is after a lot of hotel.
而这似乎是他的代表作之一。他的构想与今天存在的并不一样。确实如此，但你知道，全国各地都有哈里·维斯的建筑在拆除，那个时期的几乎所有建筑师都是如此。所以，一个从未打算对公众开放的地方内部被改变了，这只是一件小事。你知道，毕竟它是一个酒店。
Even if the warden had let Dan into the MCC, it wasn't the MCC that he wanted to see. For that matter, it wasn't the MCC that Harry Weiss wanted either. This is Chicago. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Dan Weisman and me Roman Mars. This program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more and see the punch card building for yourself, go to 99%invisible.org. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即使典狱长让丹进入了MCC，那也不是他真正想看的MCC。从这个角度讲，这也不是哈里·维斯想要的MCC。这里是芝加哥。本周的《99%隐形》由丹·韦斯曼和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。本节目由Lunar赞助支持，用创意创造改变。这是旧金山本地公共广播电台KALW 91.7、旧金山美国建筑师学会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息并亲眼看看打孔卡大楼，请访问 99%invisible.org。你 你 这个单集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。